how are you doing
i'm good how are you steve i'm doing
excellent
uh let me start by saying congrats on
the movie i had a blast watching it
i love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of movies and
hearing stuff that you know you don't
normally hear what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of snake eyes
it's such an action-packed film and i
think
it is got quite a serious tone so people
might be surprised
that we were having such a blast on it
and like some of the
more serious takes we couldn't stop
laughing sometimes
i think we were filming at you know at 4
00 a.m
in japan and it was freezing this is so
long ago now this is like
what a year and a half two years ago i
was gonna make a joke and say it was
five years ago but go on
it feels like five years ago um
and especially ursula and i we i think
we were just delirious with the
with being tired and in these you know
these suits
that were a bit uncomfortable and we
would just
start laughing and i think we've
probably ruined a couple of tantrics
i'll add to that and say i think a lot
of people don't realize that although
the costumes you wear in the movie
look awesome they're [ __ ] to be in
i know the costumes look so good and the
costume design did such an incredible
job louise is amazing
but yes they're not the most practical
and they're quite hard to actually do
stunts and fights
in but they look so cool so
like you gotta do it absolutely i think
a lot of people are curious who are
hardcore
gi joe fans uh in the comics the cartoon
your character and snake eyes have had
relationships
in the past and i'm curious if that's
something that you guys have talked
about
uh wanting to pursue and say you got to
make a sequel
i haven't been privy to such
conversations about
scarlet and snake eyes but
i wouldn't say no got it
one of the things that i learned about
you that i think is really cool is your
stunt double uh jackie has been with you
since ash vs evil dead
yeah uh talk a little bit i was gonna
say talk a little bit about
your relationship and the fact that you
guys have been together for so long
i love jackie so much she's such a
badass she makes me look so cool
um she does all the hard lifting
especially with the film like this where
it's
basically all fights she did
like she should be here not me um
she's yeah we we met in new zealand
doing ashfas evil dead and
we really got along and she was a really
good match for me um
i think some films struggle finding a
good match for me
um and yeah with snake eyes i just
mentioned her name i said you know if
you're happy they were
having trouble finding someone again and
i said let's use jackie and they did and
then she was we could hang out in japan
and it was so much fun
uh before i run out of time with you uh
you're filming something that i'm
incredibly excited about
i believe you're filming it right now um
yeah exactly
uh what what can you yeah i know what
can you tease about
uh the film and what excited you about
being part of a project that
literally has everyone in it
babylon maybe that maybe yeah maybe
that's it
it's very surreal and incredible and i'm
just very honored to be
a part of it now i'm scared and nervous
talking about it
i'm sure i'm not going to be the only
one who brings it up like can you just
what was it about the project that said
i want to do this damien
the other actors the cast the crew every
the
the what it's about the theme it's all
of it i can't even i don't have words
it was just absolute yes from me uh i
completely understand so what do you do
you know what you're gonna do after
babylon or how long is that gonna you
know i don't know how long it shoots for
me neither no one knows um i'm heading
off to prague soon
to film chevalier with calvin harris jr
which will be cool
that's awesome uh okay well i'm out of
time i'm just gonna say
again congrats on snake eyes hope it's a
huge hit for you guys
and you get to make another thank you so
much it was lovely to see you